- All right, let's get into the best
and worst part of space.
So, every time Neil is here,
he tells me something
terrifying about the universe
that I end up Googling for weeks.
- [Neil] No, 'cause you
ask me. I don't come in.
- I know because I wanna
know, I'm a prepper, okay.
I like to be prepared.
So it's something we call...
(rock music)
♪ Neil scares Kelly half
to death with space facts ♪
(audience clapping)
- What?
Oh my god.
Oh my God, I didn't know that was coming.
(Kelly laughs)
All right, so you're welcome.
- That completely freaked
me out right there.
- Well.
- Sorry.
- You know what?
In fairness, you're about
to scare the hell out of
all of us, so go ahead.
What's one thing.
- Oh, okay.
You wanna know ways we might
die delivered by the universe?
- Yes.
- Okay.
So, we just brought back a sample
from an asteroid called Bennu.
This is an asteroid whose
orbit crosses Earth's orbit.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Any, there it goes.
And any asteroid that
crosses Earth's orbit
will one day collide with Earth.
It's just a matter of when.
Asteroid Bennu, it will
cross Earth's orbit,
and we think it could hit us
with a one in about 3000
probability in 2182.
- That's not far.
- Okay, and no, it's not far.
And the asteroid is about the size
of the Empire State Building.
So no, it won't render us extinct,
but wherever it hit would be really bad.
Okay, so, so, but 160 years,
that's plenty of time
to find Bruce Willis.
- Exactly.
(Neil laughs)
- [Neil] No.
- Get him up there.
- There's plenty of time to
figure out how we might--
- There's no way to protect us from that?
- No!
(audience laughing)
No.
(Neil laughs)
No, we have no, there are no-
- Why don't you shoot at it?
- No, there's no plans right
now to deflect anything.
We are sitting ducks
and you know the dinosaurs,
had they had a space program,
they'd still be here.
(audience laughing)
- I love you so much.